mais d'abord donc un président qui
plonge dans la bataille des législatives
juste avant de s'envoler vers l'Europe
de l'Est et les bruits de bottes en
Ukraine c'est le fait politique du jour
avec Jérôme Rabier
le duel à distance se poursuit entre la
Nupe et les partisans du président de la
République le Conseil des ministres de
cette semaine a été avancé pour cause de
visite en Roumanie et Moldavie
d'Emmanuel Macron mais avant de décoller
pour soutenir les forces françaises
déployées sur place le chef de l'État a
lancé un appel aux électeurs pour le
second tour insistant sur les
conséquences d'un résultat serré mais
parce qu'il en va de l'intérêt supérieur
de la nation je veux aujourd'hui vous
convaincre de donner dimanche
une majorité solide au pays
nous avons besoin d'une majorité solide
pour assurer l'ordre à l'extérieur comme
à l'intérieur de nos frontières une
prise de parole pour aussi appeler un
sursaut républicain face à l'abstention
mais la cible est bien l'Alliance de
gauche emmenée par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
toutes les composantes de la majorité
insistent sur le risque d'une majorité
relative à l'image d'Édouard Philippe
dans les colonnes du Figaro le désordre
politique qui viendrait s'ajouter à
l'instabilité et au danger du monde
actuel serait une folie de son côté
Jean-Luc Mélenchon tente également de
mobiliser il en appelle lui aussi aux
abstentionnistes et en particulier aux
jeunes en martelant ce qui l'opposent au
projet présidentiel impossible d'avoir
un débat sur la retraite à 65 ans sur le
travail forcé au RSA impossible d'avoir
un débat pendant la campagne président
sur leur budget caché ils vont enlever
80 milliards impossible d'avoir un débat
sur l'eau on avait déjà pas pu la voir
pendant la présidentielle là non plus
donc je pense que tout se joue du fait
que les gens qui nous écoutent en ce
moment le plus grand parti de ce pays
c'est 25 millions d'abstentionnistes le
leader de la nuque qui aurait souhaité
un débat avec la première ministre une
proposition qu'Elisabeth borne aurait
refusé selon lui faux réponds Matignon
qui a décliné un rendez-vous sur France
TV ce jeudi pour cause de campagne
locale dans le Calvados a défaut dans
tête à tête le duel se poursuivra donc à
distance respectable sur le terrain et
par plateau interposé
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder dans ce
premier débat politique on commence donc
par le discours d'Emmanuel Macron et je
vous présente mes invités Bérengère
Bonte bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste essayiste auteur de cette
biographie d'Édouard Philippe Le Sioux
publié aux éditions de l'archipel
Stéphane zumsteg bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directeur du département Opinion de
lassitude
ipso j'accueille également Etienne
hollyon bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sociologue chercheur au CNRS auteur de
ce livre les candidats novices et
professionnels en politique c'est au
presse universitaire de France
j'accueille également Laetitia cru pas
bonsoir Laetitia bienvenue à vous aussi
Bérengère bon je commence avec vous ce
cette prise de parole surprise quand
même d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'elle
donnait un petit un petit aspect
improvisation quand même est-ce que vous
l'avez vécu comme ça ou pas sur la forme
en tout cas clairement d'autant que
Édouard Philippe
Emmanuel Macron était
[Musique]
dans la maison Macron Laetitia comment
vous le si on parle de la forme et
ensuite je vous donnerai la parole sur
le fond mais effectivement cette prise
de parole alors on peut on peut dire
aussi que c'est un coup de communication
réussie puisque on en parle on ouvre
cette émission avec avec cette prise de
parole comment vous analysez vous total
cuisant c'est surréaliste cette séquence
elle est absolument pas improvisée parce
qu'il y a un pupitre il y a un discours
écrit avec des feuilles ou alors il l'a
fait 10 minutes avant mais je peux pas y
croire c'est surréaliste en fait on est
entre les deux tours d'une élection qui
concerne directement les Français le
quotidien l'opposition en tout cas a
imposé ces thèmes dans la campagne il y
a eu le boulevard pour le faire et
manuel Macron choisit on le savait
depuis la semaine dernière donc c'est un
choix qui a été programmé qui assumait
de s'envoler pour la Roumanie et
peut-être pour l'Ukraine parce que c'est
ce qui reste encore on ne sait pas on en
est pas sûr non on en est pas sûr et les
lycée refuse de le dire même aux
journalistes qui accompagnent le
Président j'ai posé la question et
journaliste qui est dans l'avion qui est
parti juste avant Emmanuel Macron
eux-mêmes ne savent pas voyez-vous donc
il laisse planer comme ça ce mystère
mais quel est le sens Thomas d'un
président qui s'envole alors certes il y
a une guerre en Europe en tout cas aux
portes de l'Europe en Ukraine mais qui
s'envole alors que les Français sont
absolument
concentrés sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
l'âge des retraites sur toutes les
thématiques qui vont considérer
directement leur quotidien Stéphane
zumsega en terme d'efficacité on voit
bien à qui s'adresse il s'adresse à ces
électeurs de la présidentielle qui sont
pas déplacés dimanche dernier et ça
c'est d'ailleurs ils étaient est-ce
qu'on les a comptabilisés les
abstentionnistes du camp du camp Macron
je sais pas c'est si vous avez la
réponse mais déjà il y a deux fois plus
de Français qui ne se sont pas déplacés
après dans le détail pas vraiment
l'électorat de ma chronique c'est un peu
plus mobilisé que d'autres mais il y a
pas de vrai il y a pas eu de vrai césure
entre entre un électorat mélenchoniste
qui aurait plus ou moins voté
l'électeurs macroniste
d'électeurs macronistes qui sont pas
allés voter avant-hier
majoritaire partout après ceci dit on le
sait bien quand on regarde la structure
de du vote Macron c'est un vote de
personnes âgée beaucoup plus que de
personnes jeunes et ce sont les
personnes les plus civiques et se sont
elles qui se déplacent le plus donc
quand il y a de l'abstention c'est pas
vraiment lui qui empathique après sur sa
déclaration ce sont des placements mais
ils nous refait le coup du chef de
guerre en fait ce qu'il avait fait bien
avant l'élection présidentielle on avait
bien vu que ça l'avait énormément servi
au tout début des événements en Ukraine
notamment auprès de cet électorat
âgé qui a besoin de se réassurer et
aussi auprès de l'électorat de droite
qu'il avait totalement siphonné au-delà
de toute espérance au soir du premier
tour en tout cas quand on voit ce
qu'avait fait Valérie Pécresse donc sa
stratégie elle est claire c'est
continuer à taper à taper à taper et de
le faire de façon un peu moins agressive
qu'auparavant sur le tout sauf Mélenchon
sur le péridot il parle de désordre il
parle pas de programme économique
irréalisme ne parle pas encore de sortie
de l'OTAN de choses comme ça c'est moins
agressif que ce qu'on peut dire un
certain nombre de ses soutiens ces
derniers jours et notamment depuis
depuis dimanche soir dernier ne pas
ajouter au désordre il joue quoi il joue
la carte de la cohérence qui n'a pas
fonctionné c'est son comme son principal
échec du premier tour votez pour vous
avez voté pour moi bien donnez-moi une
majorité ce qui a toujours fonctionné
enfin en tout cas la plupart du temps
depuis l'inversion du calendrier
institutionnel et qui n'a pas du tout
fonctionné dimanche dernier c'est soyez
cohérent je suis président vous avez
tranché il y a 2 mois on peut penser ce
qu'on veut de cet argument mais
donnez-moi une majorité
Étienne au lion alors là il y a le chef
de guerre Laetitia dit finalement un peu
un président écartelé entre les enjeux
internationaux et puis cette campagne
dans lequel il veut quand même peser et
vous comment vous l'analysez cette prise
de parole je ne suis pas spécialiste de
communication politique donc je laisse
ça à d'autres mais il me semble en effet
que sur le fond je rejoins ce que disait
votre invité c'est-à-dire que on est
dans une séquence qui assez clairement
montre que le Président de la République
et cette pesé sur la campagne alors il
le fait avec des termes un petit peu
différents il est pas dans les discours
qu'on a pu avoir cette semaine mais dès
dimanche soir comme vous le rappeliez on
a eu en effet une série de rappels à
l'ordre en disant il va falloir aller
voter sinon le danger ça va être le
désordre qu'on entend aujourd'hui
ou cette mise en équivalence moi qui m'a
beaucoup frappé entre la nups et le
Front National qui dès le soir de la
présidentielle est réalisé par Elisabeth
borne quand elle prend la parole elle
dit les extrêmes en fait et puis qui
ensuite va être enchaîné on l'a dit
Amélie de Montchalin Gabriel Attal alors
dans ça on a des gens qui prennent des
positions un peu différentes Clément
Beaune ministre de l'Europe lui a dit à
titre personnel je vais appeler à voter
pour la nuque mais on est quand même ici
si on prend un tout petit peu de recul
dans un registre rhétorique du Nini ni
l'anus ni le Front national ni le
rassemblement national qui est celui qui
a longtemps été celui de l'UMP puis des
républicains en fait c'est le registre
rhétorique de je ne veux pas avoir à
choisir et donc ça dit quelque chose
peut-être du positionnement futur de en
marche mais en tout cas ça dit quelque
chose de l'inquiétude qui est en train
de les saisir et de ce point de vue là
ils font assez peu de cas de quelque
chose qui existait jusqu'à peu qui
s'appelle le Front républicain front
républicain qu'on n'a pas du tout en
train qu'on ne voit pas ce produire à
l'heure actuelle et ça je trouve que
c'est un déplacement qui si on
s'intéresse au long terme et assez
significatif Emmanuel Macron qui a dans
le même discours à lancer cet appel
invoquant la République écoutez bien la
formule que le président a choisi
nous sommes à l'heure des choix
et les grands choix ne se font jamais
par l'abstention
j'en appelle donc avant votre bon sens
et aux sources républicains
ni abstention ni confusion mais
clarification
dimanche aucune voix ne doit manquer à
la République
dimanche je compte sur vous pour doter
notre pays d'une majorité solide afin
d'affronter tous les défis de l'époque
et de bâtir l'espoir
aucune voix ne doit manquer à la
République moi c'est vraiment c'est ce
passage là qui m'a frappé voté pour la
République sous-entendu la République
c'est moi ça nous rappelle quelqu'un
d'ailleurs c'est clair à peu près je
pense un bon nombre de prison de la
République qui en pari circonstances se
sont approprié effectivement
la République et le je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord quand vous dites on est
dans des dans des propos moins violents
peut-être les mots sont moins violents
mais aucune voix ne doit dans ce cas la
République ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que si on vote nuque ou RN on vote
contre la République
on n'est pas on n'est pas dans dans on
n'est même pas dans ce que Élisabeth
borne laisse entendre et dans dans la
cacophonie des 48 dernières heures on
est dans ensemble ou rien
c'est quand même euh
il faut quand même écouter aussi ce
qu'on dit tous les lieux étonnants les
uns après les autres sur cette
expression du Nini ils explicite le pas
la nuque pourquoi pas la nuque parce que
il dit que il faudra regarder au cas par
cas mais que certains candidats nus peut
se sont affichés avec des personnes qui
sont clairement antisémites reconnus
comme tel ou qui se sont affichés avec
des personnes ou eux-mêmes sont contre
les principes de laïcité après il
faudrait demander à l'éclairage c'est
les termes c'est les sauf c'est la liste
des sauf dans le dans la dernière prise
de parole d'Élisabeth donc il est
considère comme anti républicain donc
voilà
il dit doivent aller vers la République
mais il faudrait qu'il soit plus clair
dans ces cas-là allons-y allons dans le
naimation Thomas vous voyez cette
méthode nommée et de porter la honte sur
puisque ce sont des candidats qu'il faut
fuir et bien il faut expliciter pourquoi
pourquoi ces candidats avec qui se
sont-ils affichés quelles sont leurs
propos qui sont anti républicains etc
etc c'est sans doute pas au président de
la République de de le faire mais
peut-être à certains de ces lieutenants
et Étienne hollyoncé ça rejoint ce qui
vous dit tout à l'heure cette prise de
parole il a invoqué l'intérêt supérieur
de la nation le président de la
République donc il y avait une stratégie
de dramatisation des enjeux
dramatisation certaine en effet mais moi
en effet je me pose la question si il y
a des personnes qui sont considérées
comme anti républicaine je suis d'accord
avec vous je pense qu'il faudrait dire
et ça permettrait de sortir d'un débat
qui est purement rhétorique et assez
gazeux pour rentrer dans le détail et
qu'on aille mais alors c'est la même
chose pour le rassant pardon de nous
interroger c'est la même chose pour le
rassemblement national dans ces cas-là
ça veut dire qu'il faudrait interdire ce
parti si on considère qu'il n'est pas
républicain alors c'est pas une question
d'Inter la question de name and shame
donc de mettre à distance et de ne pas
voter pour moi en effet je suis assez
frappé par ce discours qui est quand
même un discours particulièrement
radical qui dit la République c'est moi
vous venez de le dire et alors en plus
pour faire quelque chose qui moi
m'étonne beaucoup parce que je vais pas
parler à la place de notre collection de
ici mais il me semble quand même juste
après il me semble quand même que la
question n'est pas de savoir s'ils vont
gagner ou pas cette élection c'est
possible bien sûr je suis pas
prévisionniste je ne suis pas sondeur
mais en tout cas ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est la question de la
majorité absolue qui pourrait avoir et
éventuellement de du volume de la
stabilité de cette majorité donc en fait
si le gouvernement est inquiet et que
tous les ténors sont sur les ondes en ce
moment c'est pour tenter d'éviter
d'avoir une opposition forte c'est pour
tenter d'avoir un parlement qui
fonctionne peut-être un petit peu
différemment et ça je pense que ça dit
quelque chose quand même sur l'idée
qu'ils se font du Parlement dans le
fonctionnement actuel des institutions
et on pourrait à l'inverse trouver
Parlement qui récupère un peu de sa de
sa puissance dans les semaines à venir
on verra bien effectivement Stéphane
zumsec ce qui est ce qui est intéressant
cette idée cette idée qui revient
plusieurs fois dans le discours de
d'Emmanuel Macron de majorité solide
alors continuer majorité solide on
entend majorité absolue est-ce qu'il y a
un risque de France un gouvernable ou
est-ce que c'est totalement de la de la
communication politique un gouvernable
probablement pas après oui la la
surprise de ce premier tour ça a été
évidemment les la contreperformance d'un
certain nombre de candidats de
d'ensemble évidemment et que sur la base
des résultats du premier tour est
extrêmement prudent évidemment c'est
tout ce jour à dimanche prochain
Emmanuel Macron n'est absolument pas
assuré de disposer d'une majorité
absolue ça c'est le scénario pour
l'instant le plus probable après il y a
des groupes charnières il y a des
possibilités de s'allier on a beaucoup
parlé de la possibilité de récupérer une
partie des élus qui seront qui seront
qui gagneront sur l'étiquette LR et qui
intégreront ensuite une majorité
présidentielle qui se roulait Macron
compatible Jean-François Copé le maire
de moi a clairement entendu la perche
les dimanches soirs voir tout simplement
parce que c'est un accord de
gouvernement soit au cas par cas soit
d'accord le gouvernement comme le
réclame Gérard archer d'ailleurs avec un
groupe LR qui serait qui sera forcément
amputé d'une partie importante peut-être
de la moitié de ses de ses membres mais
ce sera suffisant pour obtenir la
majorité absolue donc la France ne sera
pas un gouvernable d'assemblée trouvera
une majorité bien sûr et pour lui ce
sera quand même une terrible défaite et
ce sera quand même du jamais vu depuis
qu'on a inversé le calendrier électoral
vous n'êtes pas censé perdre des
élections législatives deux mois avec
deux mois après une réélection assez
facile et assez brillante d'ailleurs
voilà dans ce cas vous venez d'exposer
c'est pas perdre ça veut dire qu'ils
auraient
pas mais il n'aurait pas la majorité
absolue
pour réformer que le scénario n'était
pas écrit n'était pas celui-là en tout
cas la véritable inquiétude encore une
fois elle est pour les les barons de la
macronie parce que la majorité elle-même
qu'elle soit RIC rock qu'elle soit absol
ou relative en vérité toutes les
projections nous amènent quand même
autour de gère quasiment toutes les
projections pour la pour ensemble
et si c'est s'ils ne l'ont pas ils ont
quelques-unes une dizaine peut-être on
est pas Madame Soleil évidemment il faut
rester prudent mais les projections sont
pas du tout celles qui sont promises à
la au groupe Mélenchon à la nups donc le
danger il est pas là et et ensuite les
conséquences en termes démocratiques et
je veux dire la vraie inquiétude elle
est aussi du côté de l'abstention et je
suis pas sûr que le genre de
gesticulation d'aujourd'hui
convaincre grand monde de venir voter en
plus alors justement l'abstention on va
parler maintenant du vote des jeunes ou
du non vote des des jeunes regarder ces
chiffres l'abstention j'ai les 18 24 ans
en état 69%
ce dimanche pardon 25 34 ans 71 % et
puis ce comment se vote des j'y reste ce
ventile évidemment forte
fort choix pour la nuque 42% le
rassemblement national qui arrive en
seconde position 18% ensuite cet
ensemble 13% et l'air 10% reconquête 5%
et ça n'a pas échappé évidemment à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon cette abstention très
forte de son électorat puissant celui de
la jeunesse il a apostro fait les jeunes
sur France 2 hier soir écoutons je veux
juste dire aux jeunes que il ferait
quand même qu'il se mêle un peu de leurs
affaires parce que c'est pas la peine de
venir râler sur parcoursup si après
c'est pas pour voter pour ceux qui
veulent l'abolir et que puisque nous
partageons le souci de la planète bah
c'est le moment d'envoyer des gens à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vont s'y
prendre pour de bons et pour de vrai
j'admets c'est normal qu'on puisse ne
pas être d'accord avec ce que nous
proposons et même que certains États aux
caricatures qu'on a fait de nous mais
pour tous les autres qui a
d'innombrables fois ont montré leur
intérêt pour les tests que nous développ
leur dit bon alors là faut quand même il
faut faire quelque chose c'est un peu
c'est un peu la séquence du bâton on va
dire s'il y a eu la carotte un peu plus
tôt dans la campagne je ne sais pas
l'avait fait rappeler pour les
régionales ça avait été un échec total
c'est-à-dire
est-ce que c'est le meilleur moyen de
faire bouger le le vote des jeunes qui
veut répondre à cette question personne
me regarde
non mais ce qu'on sait en effet c'est
que les déterminants de l'abstention
sont très claires il y a des jeunes pour
des raisons qui sont souvent il y a
d'autres catégories socioprotiniennes
les ouvriers les personnes sans emploi
bon il y a des il y a des déterminants
assez intéressants il y a des
déterminants sociaux-démographiques
qu'on vient d'évoquer mais il y a aussi
des déterminants simplement de mauvaises
inscriptions ce que montre mes collègues
par exemple que Céline
braconnier Jean-Yves Magin c'est que si
les jeunes et des c’était intéressant le
graphique que vous montriez soit c'est
les 25 34 ans qui sont les plus les plus
abstentionnistes c'est parce que c'est
ceux qui sont en train de se déplacer
ils ont quitté leur région pour aller
voter et que si on avait des procédures
pour mieux inscrire les jeunes donc en
contrôlant par ça les jeunes voteraient
peut-être un petit peu plus et même
significativement plus et que donc avec
de la volonté pour réinscrire les jeunes
on arriverait certainement à avoir des
taux d'abstention qui te baissent assez
significativement donc parfois il y a
des petits remèdes ça suffira pas
évidemment mais ça permettrait de
déplacer et peut-être d'une électronique
le vote électronique c'est une
possibilité mais qui pose d'autres
problèmes en termes de confiance que
vous avez déjà abordé bien sûr et de
sécurité et à l'heure actuelle je suis
pas certain que on est les techniques
informatiques qui permettent vraiment de
s'assurer d'un vote qui soit vraiment
fiable et même si on les avait la peur
que ça pourrait produire serait beaucoup
plus dangereuse que le ce que ce que ça
apporte effectivement ça pourrait
affaiblir une confiance dans l'élection
qui est déjà affaiblie une mère générale
et puis pour l'instant on a tout
simplement techniquement pas de garantie
et je crois qu'il y a deux pays qui
l'avaient mis en place et qui sont
revenus en arrière parce qu'il n'avaient
pas ces garanties Stéphane je sais que
si on zoom sur l'électorat jeune qui n'a
pas voté Mélenchon cette fois-ci alors
qu'ils avaient voté c'est un peu la même
question que pour Emmanuel Macron tout à
l'heure
est-ce qu'un message comme celui-là peut
les mobiliser est-ce que ou est-ce que
c'est un c'est finalement un désintérêt
pour les législatif plus profond parce
que ce livre de toute façon on sait pas
à quoi ça sert on sait pas à quoi
servent les députés etc etc bien sûr
bien sûr qu'il y a ces éléments ça vaut
pour les jeunes comme pour les moins
jeunes mais si on parle que des jeunes
enfin les principales raisons de
l'abstention de manière générale le fait
qu'on est plus d'un Français sur deux ne
soient pas déplacés c'est que pour les
Français aujourd'hui l'élection autour
de laquelle tout s'articule ces
élections présidentielles ils ont tort
évidemment les élections législatives
c'est cruciales d'expliquer malgré tout
l'essentiel a été c'est aussi un peu de
la responsabilité d'Emmanuel Macron qui
a
choisi la stratégie de l'attente puis
d'une quasi longue campagne
cette préminence de l'élection
présidentielle il y a le fait qu'il y a
pas eu de campagne alors vraiment pas
une pour le coup c'est pas une nouvelle
campagne qui a commencé hier mais c'est
la campagne qui commence enfin il y a un
troisième élément c'est la loi sur le
cumul des mandats 2014 ça ne touche pas
que les jeunes mais
il y a plus de députés mères il y a plus
de sénateurs on ne connaît pas le nom de
son député ne connaît pas l'étiquette
politique de son député à part dans
quelques zones rurales effectivement où
les gens sont plus présents les gens
sont plus âgés lisent plus la presse
quotidienne régionale toutes ces
choses-là à partir du moment où vous ne
connaissez même pas le nom de votre
député vous votez sur quand vous votez
c'est sur étiquette politique et donc ça
contribue encore plus à nationaliser ces
élections législatives il y a toujours
eu un grand débat les législatives c'est
une c'est
577 scrutin locaux une élection
nationale dans ça n'a jamais été
véritablement tranchée mais cette année
c'est encore plus accentué que que les
autres années c'est ma contre Mélenchon
puisque de toute façon on ne connaît pas
les gens pour lesquels on va au premier
tour est-ce que c'est un peu moins vrai
au second tour puisque là on a de
finalistes et on peut un peu plus s'y
intéresser vous voyez ce que ça vous
votez
majorité absolue pour Macron ou alors un
peu plus de un peu moins de pouvoir en
tout cas on refuse les pleins pouvoirs
au président de la République ça tourne
autour de ça et c'est un vrai problème
parce que c'est pas non plus la finalité
d'élection législative d'être un match
entre un président de la République et
quelqu'un qui
peut-être s'autonomie ou phosphère et
dire président Premier ministre c'est
pas du tout ça des institutions et c'est
exactement ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
compris parce qu'hier au 20 heures il a
bien dit que ce deuxième tour était un
référendum anti Macron en disant bien sa
référendum anti-macron politique pas
contre sa personne mais c'est de cette
façon qu'il l'a présenté donc il appelle
les anti Macron à venir mettre un
bulletin Nupe dans le cas d'un duel
encore plus clair là-dessus mais moi je
moi il me semble qu'il en parlait de
l'ambiguïté de d'Emmanuel Macron à ne
pas à ne pas aller vers un front
républicain l'ambiguïté de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon depuis dimanche soir et quand
même aussi à souligner et n'est pas de
nature à rassurer je pense un électorat
un peu de de gauche un peu d'émo
social-démocrate qui qui hésitait
c'est-à-dire alors on met ça sous le
compte de l'absus vous savez les fâchés
les fachos et des appels qu'il a lancé
mais même des dimanches soir en fait il
est il est quand même attend de la main
en gros un électorat du rassemblement
national ce qui lui pose aucun problème
tout ça dans un je sais pas moi frappé
dimanche soir j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé
pas bon Mélenchon j'ai trouvé quand il
veut être clair il s'est être clair
Jean-Luc Mélenchon là je l'ai trouvé
sans vert et sans et sans voilà il
entretient cette espèce de flou qui est
quand même assez problématique aussi je
reviens sur cette idée d'étiquette
nationale Étienne au Lyon votre livre
les candidats nos vies ces
professionnels en politique où on a tous
vu dans dans cette campagne de
législatives des des candidats
essentiellement et reine je ne crois pas
me tromper qui se retrouvait dans des
débats locaux sur les télés locales et
qui étaient incapables de répondre à des
questions à peu précises et ben
j'entendais ce matin une chronique sur
RTL qui qui faisait la liste de quelques
unes de ces candidates en l'occurrence
c'était des femmes qui sont arrivés en
tête au premier tour de législatives
alors qu'elle s'était ridiculisée ils
sont un plateau télé c'est bien la
démonstration finalement on vote pour
celui qui est à côté sur la photo en
l'occurrence c'était Marine Le Pen c'est
certain qu'on a des logiques
d'étiquettes qui fonctionnent à plein
dans ce genre d'élection alors le cumul
des mandats en effet ou la fin du cumul
demanda à participer de cette séparation
là aussi participé d'autre chose c'est
de du désintérêt des élus pour le
Parlement moi j'ai de plus en plus de
parlementaires qui me disent je préfère
avoir une mairie un espace local parce
que d'une certaine manière si je suis là
j'ai plus de sécurité électorale je suis
pas soumis aux alternants ça la volonté
de mon parti et puis j'ai plus de moyens
aussi pour agir politique levier
d'action et donc alors voilà être
honnête comme dirait Edouard Philippe
qui avait avant de prendre de devenir
Premier ministre choisis de retourner au
Havre et puis et puis aussi des moyens
des équipes en fait pour vous aider à
faire de la politique localement et la
politique ça se fait pas tout seul mais
en effet on se retrouve à l'heure
actuelle avec des logiques de liste
alors il faut rappeler qu'une logique de
liste et de d'étiquettes elle fonctionne
toujours on les avait eu en 2017 avec
les candidats d'Emmanuel Macron
la même chose qui n'est pas connu pour
la bonne raison que bah une partie
d'entre eux n'était pas en politique
avant et qu'ils avaient de bonnes
raisons on a l'exemple le plus
caricatural de cette logique de liste à
mon avis pour partie assez différent
cette fois-ci le parti animaliste qui
avait mis un canard sur ses affiches
donc le nom du candidat n'était même pas
mentionné et de l'autre côté les députés
reconquêtes qui avaient envoyé des des
grands quatre pages quadricchromées mais
qui était sans même le nom du candidat
et c'est seulement dans le le certains
bureau de vote qu'on allait découvrir le
nom à la limite pourquoi pas d'une
certaine manière ça veut dire aussi
qu'on vote pour des idées il y a même un
parti le Parti Pirate qui a dit ne votez
pas pour nous votez pour nos idées 577
fois donc d'une certaine manière c'est
pas gênant d'ailleurs si on avait une
proportionnelle avec un scrutin de liste
c'est ce qui se passerait on aurait
trois têtes d'affiches et puis voilà
mais il est certain que la notabilité
comme ressource et quelque chose qui
s'est perdu en politique contemporaine
en partie à cause de cette question du
cumul des mandats alors dans la future
Assemblée il y en a qui pourrait jouer
un rôle crucial et on va ouvrir ce
chapitre dans ce débat c'est Edouard
Philippe Laetitia sont partis horizons
ces distingués Scorps plutôt honorable
dans les 58 circonscriptions où il a
présenté des candidats 24 sortent en
tête on se pose donc cette question
est-ce qu'il un atout jusqu'au bout pour
Emmanuel Macron ou peut-être un boulet
et bien je vais vous répondre les deux
tomates tout dépend du temps que l'on
prend en considération si c'est un temps
court c'est un atout puisque une voix
même molle est une voix et on est donc
encore dans une période électorale et
sur le temps long Édouard Philippe sera
certainement un danger et un boulet en
tous les cas pour Emmanuel Macron on va
commencer par le début Édouard Philippe
il avait dit je vais mouiller ma chemise
pour pour cette campagne bon je ne sais
pas résultat des courses j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il est tout donné donc
il était là c'est vrai il a fait comme
ça quelques petites apparitions il a
soutenu mollement Emmanuel Macron et
puis pour les législatives il est monté
sur scène lui aussi dans un meeting par
exemple on va l'écouter à Nice le 8 juin
pour soutenir les candidats d'ensemble
mon message c'est un message de
mobilisation de cohérence c'est aussi un
message de lucidité nous vivons une
période qui est difficile avec des
fragilités françaises avec des
déséquilibres mondiaux qui s'accélèrent
et pour faire face à cette situation il
faut que le président puisse avoir une
majorité stable et solide aucun Français
ne peut croire qu'avec du désordre de
l'incohérence au sein de la
représentation nationale et au sommet de
l'État nous puissions trouver les bonnes
solutions et faire face à cette période
finalement dans cette période électorale
le maître mot d'Edouard philippe est un
peu le positionnement c'est la loyauté
pour celui qui l'a nommé à Matignon en
2017 alors qu'il était totalement
inconnu et donc bon on pourrait le
trouver peut-être un peu économe dans
l'émotion dans les mots peut-être aide à
l'instar d'Alain Juppé qui est son
mentor mais en tous les cas cette image
et cette posture tient encore une fois
la tête dans les hits parades de la
popularité il pourra aussi
éventuellement si on se projette là
peut-être un peu plus sur le temps long
j'ai aimé Emmanuel Macron avec un groupe
à l'Assemblée
[Applaudissements]
pas mal par Emmanuel Macron qui reste
quand même très flou alors lui sont
désolidaris carrément il dit qu'il a pas
du tout été associé à la réflexion et il
laisse quand même entrevoir un léger
scepticisme il dit par exemple rien ne
peut concurrencer l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat ce sont deux chambres qui
discutent et vote la loi il serait
absurde de vouloir remplacer le
Parlement par autre chose ce n'est
évidemment pas l'objectif du président
ça c'est tout le style Philippe loyauté
en vitrine mais hop une petite pique et
un petit message quand on lit bien entre
les lignes et donc oui définitivement il
peut le faire de l'ombre à Emmanuel
Macron qui lui-même le sait
rappelez-vous l'épopée personnelle
d'Emmanuel Macron vis-à-vis de François
Hollande qui l'a quand même fini par
trahir et bien écoutez peut-être qu'il
voir Philippe aura le même destin ça ce
sera rendez-vous en 2027 puisque
Emmanuel Macron ne se représentera pas
effectivement bérengerbon vous avez
enquêté sur la personnalité des droits
Philippe pour votre livre Le le Siou
qu'est-ce qui caractérise aujourd'hui la
relation entre les deux hommes est-ce
que le mot moi le mot qui me vient c'est
peut-être le mot méfiance mais est-ce
que c'est celui-là que vous pourriez
emprunter en premier ou un autre
moi je dirais qu'il y a pas de relation
d'accord l'absence de relation l'absence
de relation et c'est quelqu'un qui fait
peur manifestement au fameux entourage
parce qu'effectivement
son arme de guerre c'est sa popularité
je dirais que les mois passent et
elle ne diminue pas et puis aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un qui va avoir un groupe
parlementaire c'est quasiment certain
entre 21 et 26 députés dans les
projections qui j'ai raconté cet
après-midi il y a plus de 400 comités
locaux d'horizon
ce qui est quand même énorme quasiment
dans tous les départements il n'en
manque que quelques-uns qui allaient
financements publics assurés pour ce
pour ce mouvement avec les 58
circonscriptions tout ça réuni ça ça en
fait quand même un vire quelques mois ce
parti a été créé le 9 octobre donc il
est dans la majorité il a fait alors il
a il a été effectivement je suis assez
d'accord avec Laetitia il a été très
discret pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'est la casse beaucoup
qu'on le dise on l'a beaucoup vu en
revanche soutenir les candidats horizons
ça pour le coup il a vraiment mouillé la
chemise il était vraiment là donc voilà
mais c'était c'était mais ce qui est
assez habile parce que du coup il était
là et
d'autres de ne pas de ne pas y aller
mais il est pas complètement
aveugle aux enjeux de la présence au
Parlement ensuite il a pété jusqu'à
présent quelqu'un de relativement loyal
avec en effet potentiellement des
manœuvres en dessous mais jusqu'à
présent ça loyauté n'a pas été mise en
cause la situation est un petit peu
différente maintenant puisque Emmanuel
Macron probablement de se représentera
pas il faudrait changer la Constitution
pour ça donc ça ferait quand même
beaucoup un scénario à la poutine
medvedef je ne sais pas s'il veut se
lancer là-dedans mais Edward Philippe va
avoir certainement beaucoup plus de
marge manœuvres et d'envies désormais
mais ça rejoint ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour le on va dire la vitalité
de la vie démocratique on va avoir une
Assemblée nationale peut-être un peu un
peu moins un peu moins docile et un peu
plus volontaire mobile hétérogène alors
paradoxalement je pense que c'est le
pire cauchemar d'Edouard Philippe qui a
un grand défenseur de la 5e République
et qui lui ne souhaite pas avoir une
assemblée une assemblée indocile mais
par contre ce qui est certain c'est que
on peut revenir sur les projections
et joue aussi ce rôle de contre-pouvoir
notamment avec les commissions d'enquête
ou alors c'est ces auditions et
j'appelle Jérémy icemann à nous
rejoindre bonsoir Jérémy ces auditions
sur le fiasco du Stade de France elles
se sont poursuivies aujourd'hui avec les
responsables de la SNCF et de la RATP et
oui après le ministre de l'Intérieur la
ministre des Sports le préfet de police
et la Fédération Française de Football
les sénateurs de la commission Culture
et de la commission des lois continuent
leurs auditions pour comprendre et bien
comment la finale de la Ligue des
Champions entre le Real Madrid et
Liverpool organisé le 28 mai dernier au
stade de France à tourner au fiasco les
responsables de la SNCF et de la RATP
ont d'abord rappelé que leur rôle se
limite au bornes des gares et ne
concerne donc pas directement le staff
de France ni ses alentours ils assurent
en plus avoir mis en place un dispositif
inédit pour gérer un afflux de voyageurs
40% supérieures à la moyenne habituelle
selon leur chiffre qui sont en fait
assez similaires à se présenter par le
ministre de l'intérieur on comptait au
Stade de France à 21h ce soir là
36000 personnes arrivées par la ligne 13
du métro 6200 via le RER B une ligne qui
connaissait d'ailleurs une grève
partielle 37000 voyageurs via le RER D
soit trois fois plus que d'habitude sur
cette ligne et c'est là en fait que le
problème se pose parce que c'est une
surcharge qui est assez endroit va créer
des difficultés d'accès au stade pour
les spectateurs et qui selon la RATP n'a
pas été signalé par la FFS ni par le
préfet de police on écoute
on a les contacts avec la FFS à aucun
moment on a eu la moindre alerte de
quiconque qui a un problème sur la ligne
D et sortie des voyageurs de la ligne D
personne nous a dit parce qu'on aurait
pu éventuellement réorienter en temps
réel mais personne nous a alerté qui
avait votre difficulté et si on nous a
demandé de dévier des flux pour retenir
des trains c'est des choses que c'est un
peu faire d'accord mais il faut que vous
nous prévienne l'information donc ça
c'est pour le nombre de de spectateurs
c'était l'un des points chauds de la de
la polémique l'autre ce sont les images
de vidéos surveillance alors est-ce
qu'elles ont été comme ça on a parlé de
celle du Stade de France celle de la
RATP de la SNCF et bien oui c'est ces
fameuses images alors on sait en fait
qu'aucune image du Stade de France n'a
été conservée ni par les organisateurs
ni par la FFF faute de réquisition dans
les temps donné donc ça on l'avait déjà
dit et bien pour la RATP et la SNCF
c'est un peu la même chose en fait les
vidéos sont conservées seulement en cas
d'incident ou s'il y a une réquisition
dans les 72 heures sinon en fait elles
sont effacées des données et le soir du
28 mai il y a eu un incident s'en garde
Saint-Denis et quelques vidéos
surveillance ont donc été conservées en
revanche à bord des rames aucun incident
n'a eu lieu et aucune image n'a été
gardée car non demandée à temps en fait
par les autorités comme l'esprit se
responsable de la RATP
on limite la capacité
d'enregistrement ce sont
c'est une capacité d'enregistrement qui
est connue de tous puisque on traite
7000 réquisitions par an donc nous à
partir du moment on n'était pas
réquisitionné et qu'il n'y avait aucun
incident dans nos réseaux effectivement
il y a pas il y avait pas de raison
objective de conserver ces images je
vous rappelle que la vidéoprotection est
accessoirement aussi très encadrée par
la CNIL donc on espère on respecte les
procédures que l'on met en place dans
l'entreprise
oui donc finalement vous l'aurez compris
tout le monde se renvoie un peu la balle
dans cette affaire de leur côté les
sénateurs vont continuer leurs travaux
pour essayer d'éclaircir le dossier et
je dis il devrait d'ailleurs se rendre
au Stade de France pour essayer d'en
savoir plus merci Jérémy
Stéphane zumseg est-ce que ça pèse sur
le vote cette histoire non probablement
pas parce que certes c'est un fiasco
certes on a raison d'en parler une fois
il y a pas eu de blessés graves il y a
pas eu de mort ça malgré tout même si ça
a une grande résonance d'ailleurs ça a
eu une résonance presque anormale
pourquoi on était en pleine campagne
élector mais il y avait pas de campagne
électorale donc c'est surtout il y
aurait une vraie campagne électorale je
pense qu'on en aurait moins parlé ce qui
est un petit peu gênant malgré tout pour
pour l'exécutif pour le gouvernement
c'est que ça a donné des arguments à
toutes les oppositions la nuit peut
parler de mauvais usage des forces de
l'ordre de vieux et donc sous-jacent les
violences policières la droite a pu
arriver sur le fait qu'il n'y a qu'elle
qui s'est s’occuper des questions de
sécurité qu'il y a un certain laxisme
sur toutes ces questions de gestion de
la police et de la gendarmerie vous
expliquer Emmanuel Macron et président
de la République enfin le droit d'isé la
même chose qu'en François Hollande était
président évidemment et l'extrême droite
a pu profiter du fait qu'un certain
nombre de personnes issues des banlieues
étaient intervenues dans des actes de
délinquance donc voilà il y a une sorte
de conjonction de d'alliance quelque
part subjective des oppositions qui ont
fait qu'on en a beaucoup parlé après
pour répondre clairement à votre
question est-ce que ça a un impact
électoral non Étienne oignon pour
conclure sur le rôle du de Sénat alors
là ce n'est pas une commission d'enquête
on ne se trompe pas
ces auditions finalement elles peuvent
alimenter le débat politique et voilà on
n'est pas on n'est pas du tout les
sénateurs font aussi de la politique ils
jouent le rôle de contre-pouvoir mais
ils font aussi de la politique mais ça
débouche sur pas grand chose il y a pas
il y a pas de sanctions il y a pas vous
voyez ce que dire la l'action publique
n'est pas forcément sanctionnée par ses
commissions oui ça c'est vrai c'est une
critique qu'on fait souvent assez assez
commissions mais en même temps c'est
déjà quelque chose d'important que de
porter à connaissance du public des
faits à le faire avec des pouvoirs
d'enquête dont dispose les commissions
d'enquête n'est pas une mais enfin on
peut imaginer en effet que le contrôle
du gouvernement qui est une des
fonctions du Parlement article 24 de la
Constitution passe par ces commissions
et on pourrait penser que plus de
contrôle aussi pourraient être fait que
on pourra avoir le droit à plus de
commission à droite tirage plus
important des pouvoirs plus importants
le Parlement français de ce point de vue
là et un parlement c'est une antienne de
dire ça qui est un parlement faible du
point de vue la législation c'est aussi
un parlement un peu faible du côté du
contrôle et on pourrait imaginer toute
une série de dispositifs qui sans avoir
des pouvoirs de justice parce que c'est
pas leur objectif participe à établir la
vérité merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le titre de vos livres respectifs le
Sioux c'est publié Bérengère aux
éditions de l'archipel et puis les
candidats novices et professionnels en
politique au presse universitaire de
France merci encore à tous les trois